make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we are getting back into Super Girl
infected which is to say Super Girl who
is infected like the Super girl who lost
vs Batman is Superman this is kind of
nuts but first things first
I do wanna let you guys know that we
have been dumping a whole lot of full
stories recently like making like mega
full stories different things like that
we did a whole bunch of full story
videos with the individual story arcs
from Green Lantern but I want to start
ramping up and covering Green Lantern
again so what we're gonna do here is in
the next couple days we're gonna take
all the full stories we've done and
combine them into like a mega full story
the people on patreon already have it
they got it a few days early but uh it's
basically going to be like this nine
hour Green Lantern video it's the
longest full story video we've done I'm
curious to see how people respond to
nine hours like what I want to do I want
to max out the Youtube upload write the
most you can upload to YouTube is 128
gigabytes I'm gonna see if we can do
that like I want to see if we can if we
can like exceed that I feel like I
didn't being like a 15 hour long video
but I'm curious if you guys are gonna
watch nine hours of Green Lantern it's
kind of nuts right like that's an insane
amount of content but uh but yeah so
getting into this in the last video we
basically talked about how the Supergirl
you have Supergirl herself had actually
intercepted a Batarang that was meant
for Superman to turn him into the
Superman who lost and the result was
that she was infected instead this is
kind of cool right because this feels a
lot I don't know maybe you guys remember
this far back but it feels a lot like
the like like the Red Lanterns Supergirl
and NBC does that right you know a
little bit of exposition here a little
bit explanation DC does that with
Supergirl um Kara zor-el is one of these
characters where she's been popular but
only under certain circumstances right
the original run of her character was
incredibly popular right like the
original super girl who went who was a
backup feature in the Action Comics
stories and then eventually got her own
solo feature in the adventure comic
stories she was really really popular
right but that was all before crisis on
Infinite Earths the issue was that after
crisis happened uh Superman went back to
being the status quo of the last
survivor of Krypton right and he
couldn't be the last survivor of Krypton
like the last Son of Krypton if there
was like another Kryptonian out there so
they ended up kind of getting like this
weird other dimensional version some
kind of shape-shifting manifesting thing
that basically became the new Supergirl
it wasn't really the same and then
eventually Kara zor-el returned when DC
was like whatever just bring her back
who cares and fans that fans enjoyed it
but it's one of these things where like
people don't really read her stories all
the time but if it's something kind of
kooky and exotic that happens
to her like she becomes a Red Lantern or
becomes the super girl who lost then
people are really interested right and a
lot of that's rooted back to the fact
that in you know during the crisis under
fitted her story she was more powerful
than Superman right it was one of those
things that DC had kind of hit on
periodically for a while and then
basically confirmed during the crisis
story but this basically picks up with
her kind of looking around after she's
become the Supergirl who lasts and then
just sort of kind of taking on the
stance of like she's truly gonna fix the
world and she's truly gonna make the
world a better place now here's the
thing Jody Hauser's writing sometimes is
really really good and other times it's
kind of like I'm not really sure where
she's going with this
but I do love what she's doing here
right because when it comes to the
various Kryptonians that exist in DC
Comics they always pull their punches
right we see that happen multiple times
and it's been confirmed multiple times
over the course of DC Comics that
Superman pulls his punches that if we
saw Superman fight like outright with
all the strength that he that he
potentially has he could potentially
destroy the world right the cool thing
about this is that her showing up and
basically doing things like rescuing a
bus and so on and so forth one of the
things that you kind of notice here is
that she's kind of become the darker
version of herself not really evil but
almost really just kind of like like
obsessed with herself and so far as like
I'm the most important thing ever and
this manifests in the form of like yes
this bus is saved but instead of like
tending to the passengers and doing what
we would expect you to do which is say
is anybody okay is everybody all right
instead she's just like you're welcome
I've done a fine job and she like pat
yourself on the back and then goes about
her business and does her thing and
that's the kind of crazy situation is
because she immediately goes after the
bus driver right and the response here
is like these kids almost died and it
was all it was it was almost because of
you but it was if there's no questions
of like what happened here you know did
a tire blowout like dude like were you
drinking on the job play no those
questions were asked is immediately the
assumption that like this guy screwed up
and like he now has to pay the price
right it's a very heavy-handed approach
but it's always kind of a criticism of
like I know what's right 100% of the
time I kind of adopted that mentality
what does it Philip DeFranco said why be
informed when you have your opinion is
that kind of concept sort of thrown into
the comic insofar as she's just sort of
you know she's carried away with herself
now the good thing about this is that
Jodie Howser strikes a balance it be
very very easy to kind of go down like
the hardcore political scene but we get
just enough to works like okay so she's
basically become super arrogant and
super self-obsessed
but not so much where it's like all
right now I'm reading a political
message if it's done right political
could be amazing we're a really good
example of that God loves man kills if
it's not really good well then you
basically get the first two years of
Marvel after all-new all-different so
yeah the cool thing about this is that
of course Superman shows up here and
this is where things begin to shift
because again for anybody who'd been
reading Supergirl for any real measure
of time the first thing they'll tell you
is that during the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths she was the last one
standing right all the versions of
Superman nicholae superboy-prime all
those guys had fallen and she was the
only one left who was powerful enough to
do really any kind of any kind of damage
or really even stand a chance against
the anti-monitor now she didn't say
everything right that all basically came
down to the specter but at the end of
the day she basically outlasted
everybody else and people kind of look
to that as the perspective of she's
stronger than Superman when you take
that and you couple it with a lot of the
things we've seen confirmed along the
way between the time that she reappeared
after after crisis on Infinite Earths
going into like new 52 and in DC
universe rebirth and that kind of a
thing that she's just this really heavy
hitter and that's kind of what goes on
here is because she basically tells
Superman but you're a half-measure
right like you could fix the world you
could punish the criminals but you could
go to all these people who are
committing all these crimes and say
you're done now and the response of
Superman is but that's not why I'm here
and that's the beauty behind the
character uh Superman right as well it's
why Superman and Batman are such
incredibly amazing superheroes is
because what you end up having here is a
scenario or Superman's like yeah I mean
I could do that right but if he did he'd
become no different than like the crime
syndicate from Earth 3 he would bend the
world to his whim right it would be
injustice Superman we've seen that play
out now ultimately it's this idea that
like super her Supergirl kind of looks
at him as a guy who pulls his punches
and the result is that she absolutely
thrashes Superman now she doesn't beat
him within an inch of his life or
anything like that
but it's made clear in no uncertain
terms that she's not pulling punches and
she chose to she could absolutely pummel
him and that's kind of a big moment here
it's a pretty significant thing right
because it really kind of ties into the
historical aspect of Lee scene with her
character that she's more powerful than
Superman and so after he basically ends
up falling at the hands of Supergirl
then you have Batman who shows up and
this is a really this is really like
shady moment here right like you're
Supergirl being like shady as hell Nick
is like she makes this comment to him
you know where he's like you know she's
like I'm not one of your teenagers you
can control how many of those kids have
you gotten killed and it's like
man like you that minutes cutting
deep-drawn blood son that's pretty
brutal
the Batman basically calls it for what
it is you're an impetuous child right
like you're an impatient child with no
patience who's basically been given
these godlike powers and doesn't know
how to control them Superman sees you as
his cousin and that's nice and that's
cute I see you for what you are a danger
in a threat no one knows what direction
you're gonna go in if you're gonna snap
in just a story everybody and to a
degree that's kind of true right
Superman has had decades to prove
himself to show what he is and what he's
about Supergirl is still relatively new
on the scene she's not brand new like
she didn't show up in like three years
ago or anything like that but she
certainly hasn't had as much time to
earn the trust of Batman in the way that
Superman has and even with Superman it
took a long long time right that man
doesn't really trust anybody and so as a
result of that Supergirl basically
immediately targets targets benomar she
takes out the batwing sends that flying
down to the ground rips the door off and
is like still hiding behind your toys
you know what that reminds me of I don't
know how many of you guys remember it
but it reminds me of original sin right
when basically there was this story
where you ended up finding out that that
Bruce Banner believed that Tony Stark
was the one responsible for him becoming
the Incredible Hulk in the first place
actually the Hulk manifest it kind of
goes on this warpath and like Iron Man
is just like fleeing for his life right
he's just like jumping from armor to
armor and that eventually gives his
hands on the on the Hulkbuster armor and
The Incredible Hulk comes walking into
the room and he's like always the
optimist Tony as if you really had a
chance with that suit of armor anyway
and then basically crushes the armor
around
Iron Man brothers one of the coolest
moments ever we cover that in original
sin and you'll find that here on the
channel I think it's actually I'm
recovered it individually or if we
covered it as part of the whole event
but you'll find that in the in the full
story that you'll find out in the
description but it's kind of a cool
little thing because Batman's response
is like yeah I don't trust you but I
don't know who you are like you're just
some kind of unknown thing that's out
there and her response is like I could
kill you if I wanted to but I'm not
because he won't let me of course her
speaking about the Batman who lost he
has his own plan for you and so as a
result she basically dismisses him
throws him away Superman rescues them
and then she takes off and it's kind of
a cool moment there because what this
does is it basically branches off into
her own individual comic right it kind
of continues on along the Supergirl plot
threads and will probably ultimately
wrap back around into the actual Batman
vs Superman line of stories at the
moment but it's a great little thing
here because what you get is essentially
this ridiculously just not really even
overpowered so much as Supergirl in her
for him when she's not pulling any
punches when she's not holding back and
when she really is taking on Batman or
Superman
with the full length of her abilities
the only reason why she didn't kill
these guys is because she chose not to
because I would submit here that if
Supergirl so wanted to choose it like if
she's so it so chose to do it she could
kill Superman it wouldn't be an easy
thing while she's not gonna like punch
him in the punch him in the head and
like shake his brain and kill him right
it's not gonna go down that fast but she
could beat him to death and it'd be kind
of a cool thing like it'd be interesting
to see like this knock-down drag-out
fight between Supergirl and Superman in
terms of who would actually win here I'm
kind of curious but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace I want to give a shout out
to Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have a lot of
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
Knossos 916 des gnosis didn't give us a
first and last name so we kind of had to
roll with it I didn't mention your last
names I thought you guys didn't want me
to throw them out there but I want to
say thank you to you all by the way your
rob4 rings should be on their way for
our honor guard members of the Rob core
for these special patrons your custom
Rob pour rings should be on their way
they're being shipped to me after that I
will have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon and your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you
[Music]